It's a shocking death that will spark a war — but
how do the final moments of House
of the Dragon differ from the book?
The final episode of Season 1 of House of
the Dragon feels like a powder keg about
to be ignited. After Aegon II is crowned king at
breakneck speed after the death of King Viserys,
events are set in motion that will soon see
Westeros engulfed in war. Obviously, Viserys
had named his daughter Rhaenyra as heir, and this
rapid move to usurp her claim by Alicent Hightower
and her father, Otto, has already created a
schism in the lords and ladies of Westeros.
However, the coronation of Aegon II is not without
its hiccups, as Princess Rhaenys manages to free
her dragon Meleys, which she uses to crash
through the floor of the Dragon Pit of King's
Landing. A rather dramatic way of establishing
where Rhaenys' loyalties may lie, Episode 10
picks up in the immediate aftermath, with Rhaenys
explaining to Rhaenyra what has just transpired.
"The Greens are coming for you,
Rhaenyra. And for your children."
Quickly summoning her council, as well as her
husband and uncle Daemon, Rhaenyra shows far more
restraint than her compatriots, who begin to plan
a war of succession pretty much straight away.
Unfortunately, Rhaenyra's calm and collective
demeanor isn't exactly rewarded later in the
episode, as her careful approach to the conflict
is shattered by the heedless actions of children.
Acknowledging that the faction now known as
the Greens has far more soldiers and allies,
Rhaenyra dispatches messengers
to every corner of Westeros,
hoping to shore up support. After ordering
her two children, Jacaerys and Lucerys,
to head to Winterfell and Storm's End, the two
brothers take to their dragons. Lucerys is sent
to Storm's End to treat with Borros Baratheon, but
he quickly realizes that somebody has beaten him
there. Coming face-to-face with his one-eyed
uncle Aemond, Lucerys is unable to convince
Borros to lend his support to his family's
side, who are now known as the "Blacks."
"Go home, pup. And tell your mother
that the Lord of Storm's End is not
some dog she can whistle up at
need to set against her foes."
Realizing that he is ill-prepared for this
negotiation, Lucerys attempts to leave. Before
he is able to depart, however, Aemond demands
that Lucerys cut out his own eye to make up
for the wound Lucerys had inflicted on Aemond in
their youth. However, Borros doesn't particularly
care for this bluster and allows Lucerys to leave.
Taking to his young dragon Arrax, who is greatly
unsettled by the ongoing intense storm, Lucerys
begins to fly back to Dragonstone. Soon, however,
he realizes that Aemond is in pursuit with
Vhagar, the largest and most fearsome dragon
in Westeros. Aemond taunts Lucerys from atop
his dragon, still demanding his eye — but both
children have trouble controlling their dragons
on account of them being untested dragonriders.
As Aemond's pursuit of Lucerys becomes more
and more dire, Lucerys' dragon Arrax is visibly
shaken, and both dragons appear to be letting
their primal instincts take over — despite the
protests of both riders. As the hunter,
Vhagar's size is incredibly apparent,
though this doesn't stop Arrax from blasting
the ancient dragon with fire. This in turn
causes Vhagar to release its full
fury upon both Arrax and Lucerys,
and in an instant both dragon and rider are
killed with a ravenous bite from Vhagar.
"Vhagar, no! No!"
This comes as a surprise to Aemond, who realizes
that his actions will have deadly consequences.
As shocking as this scene was for viewers, this
scene actually has far more nuance than what was
presented in Fire and Blood. In the grand scheme
of things, this scene is considered a defining
moment in the conflict known as the "Dance of
Dragons," and several different variations of
the story are told regarding what happened, but
all agreed upon one thing — Lucerys and Arrax
were tragically under-matched against Aemond
and Vhagar. And while you see that Aemond
is clearly disturbed by what happened in the
show, that's not how it goes down in the book.
This is on account of the nature of
the way Fire and Blood is written,
as a kind of historical document with unreliable
narrators. The book portrays the fight as one
sided and very much intentional, with Aemond
motivated primarily by revenge. There are several
stories told about the aftermath of the fight,
with some saying that Arrax's head washed ashore,
others saying that both Lucerys and Arrax were
swallowed whole, and one suggesting that Lucerys
actually survived but suffered from permanent
amnesia. Either way, Lucerys is never found.
This change in House of the Dragon
makes for a much more dynamic story,
which is important considering this moment sparks
the Targaryen civil war in Westeros. Although
Rhaenyra didn't want to strike the first blow, she
was given her wish — albeit at a terrible price.
To see Aemond realize his actions will have
disastrous consequences clearly shines a new
light on the story, and it’ll be interesting to
see how he’ll report the outcome to his family.
In an interview with Variety,
series co-creator Ryan Condal
was asked about why they decided
to make Lucerys' death an accident,
and not intentional. He clarified that
even though it is presented as an accident,
Aemond still jumped onto his dragon and chased
his nephew, so it isn't as clear-cut as a simple
mistake. Condal then explained how history
itself is messy, and how the historians and
storytellers of Westeros couldn't actually know
what was going through Aemond's head. He added:
"This is a war of many cuts that lead to a really,
really bloody wound. It adds complexity and nuance
to the character that's potentially interesting."
Discussing the future of
Aemond's story, Condal added:
"There's lots of runway to go on with Aemond as a
character and the story of the Dance. This is his
first act as a dragon rider and a warrior and it's
gone very wrong. Now what happens as a result,
and how does he respond? Those are the
questions I'm interested in as a dramatist."
Ultimately, this departure from the source
material definitely adds yet another layer
to the upcoming conflict and the way both sides
will respond — and shape the history of Westeros.